So, I've given the mic access,
and given I've also started the recording
for today's session.
Um...
So, yeah.
So today we are going to talk about a
little bit on foundations.
That is the first line of our handout,
what we had discussed.
That is the evolution of the SDLC models
and general evolution as such.
before AI,
also the evolution under the AI
acceleration.
So that is what we are going to discuss,
the module one we are going to start
today. So to give a short recap,
we in the previous session,
I actually missed to add a recap and an
agenda slide. I'll do that.
post the session.
So, we talked about the course.
What are the changes we are looking at?
We looked at what is the change which in
SDLC, what is an SDLC first of all?
And then we looked at how AI is
modernizing certain things, etc.
And what are the risks it's going to
bring in, etc. So we had a very...
basic general discussion in the previous
session. Actually,
that is basically to set the stage.
So now we'll start officially into the
course.
So we start with the evolution of SDLC
models.
And we will see how AI has changed a few
phases of this and what is the new model
we are looking at. Of course, officially,
there is no name.
came to it or we don't have a manifesto
like the agile manifesto etc but still we
will see what are the changes what impact
it is creating.
And we will see a few major shifts just
happened because of this.
So that will be a discussion for today.
Okay, so let's, as usual, have,
if you have any questions,
please interrupt me.
If you have a difference of opinion,
you can type it in the chat.
We can take that up, discuss,
because this particular course or this
particular topics we are discussing,
there is no one right answer.
So it is as non-deterministic
As the AI itself,
so we don't have a deterministic,
so if it's a data structure or a...
I got them, or I I got them with a model,
I would function.
I can give you a direct answer.
we have that here.
This is all based on experiences,
based on knowledge sharing by experts and
what is actually the entire industry is
experimenting.
So it is very natural that there are a
few things which I might say.
which might not go well,
or you might have second thoughts about
the same, etc.
So feel free to point out your opinions
in the chat, etc.
So with that note,
if you have any questions,
you can have your hand raised and you can
ask your questions as well in between.
Okay, so I have a few new questions.
learners who have joined this post also.
So again,
a welcome to all of you who have joined
for this particular session,
who have missed to join the previous
session as well.
You can go through the recording for what
we have discussed about the course, etc.
So one thing which is pending from my
side is on the a form which I was
thinking to roll out.
Basically the rollout is to understand
where each of you are there and also to
give you all an idea that
how this,
we have a diverse crowd of learners here
enrolled for this class. So that will.
Basically,
it's an attempt to normalize the range of
experiences in the room.
We will have different years of
experience,
current different AI tool usage,
plus anxiety levels also are quite
different.
So some of you might think that I might
not look uninformed.
So none of us are informed.
All of us are uninformed at various
levels.
So there is a mongering fear or there is
a little amount of anxiety.
The level is different,
but everyone has their own.
anxiety levels, et cetera.
So let's normalize the range of
experiences we have using that form.
So that is what I have to roll out.
I'm just waiting for the official WILP
e-mail coming to say that these are the
participants.
So that is why I'm just waiting.
Probably I'll close it in the next one or
two days is what I think.
So with that,
let's get into Software Development Life
Cycle. Any questions or anything?
Any initial thoughts before I start?
Yes, Mom, I just have a query.
Thank you.
Yeah, go ahead. Yes, SUNIL, right. Yes,
go ahead.
Am I audible? Yeah, so yes, yes. Hi,
ma'am. So, ma'am, like, like, I mean,
I just had this same doubt in the
previous class as well. So, here, like,
you would be sharing your...
Like what do you say the PPT and all like
you would be sharing, right?
So here when we it comes to the exam and
all like we would have a particular
syllabus to follow and to read, right?
So everything that like we would discuss
Yes.
in class,
but it's not like sometimes if we are in.
Hari or something,
we might miss a few things here or
sometimes we might not discuss everything
in deep and like how are we going to
understand like what's the syllabus for
exam here to like differentiate like
which one,
how much we have to focus and all like
which topic.
So,
the handout is a comprehensive document.
Because.
Mhm.
The course handout which is given to you
in the course page,
Okay.
that it's a comprehensive document which
talks about what is the course
description,
what are the objectives of the course,
what are the topics we are going to cover
out of this particular.
course, module wise in detail.
So there is no, just, it's not a one line.
It is, it's in detail.
What are the topics?
I'm going to strictly follow the handout
as much as possible.
If there are any deviations,
I'll keep you informed.
But whatever is in the handout,
that's your official course.
structure and that is what is will be
covered in the class.
There is the first part of the handout
gives you a detailed modular structure.
It also gives out the books and reference
material, which is again,
E.
there is another question by.
Abhinav, that books. So in the books,
there are a few books which we have
listed out in the list of textbooks and
reference materials.
So those are the materials we have today,
which are quite aligned.
So one point I want to repeat,
which I mentioned in the previous session
also,
we don't have one single textbook which
can be used as a complete textbook which
covers all aspects of this course because
this is a very new course and we are
talking about more on experiences.
We are talking about how the current
problem the industry is migrating towards.
So we don't have books.
We have books which are on the SDLC and
on the AI. But AI plus SDLC,
we have very few books which I have
listed out and they are not,
all the books which are listed down,
they are not very technically depth or it
Mhm.
doesn't cover all aspects what we are
actually planning to cover for the course.
So we have a few references.
And I will also be adding reference
section.
I was in the TEAMS plus I will also be
adding references at the end of each
class so that you can use all this
qualitatively to prepare for your exams.
And the handout also has a learning part
too.
where we talk about what is covered in
each section. That is contact session one,
what do I cover, contact session two,
what do I cover.
So that's a learning plan,
but that is a plan I will try to stick to,
but there are instances where I might...
fill over to the other sections also,
because depending on the Q&
A and the amount of discussion we are
taking. So the part two of the handout,
that is the part B learning plan is
something I cannot assure that we will be
following to the dot because there will
be a lot of spillovers.
We might have additional sessions or we
might have some office hours.
to generally discuss about the course.
So that is going to change.
But the first part is something which is
for your reference to answer your
question.
That is what is what the course covers.
And PPT, I've made,
since we don't have a single textbook or
it's a very new course,
I've tried to make the PPTs as elaborate
as possible,
so which can also serve as your learning.
resources.
In addition to what is covered in the PPT,
you have to refer to the reference
sections which are in.
there. So the PPT,
I'm uploading it in the course page in
your Takshila, as well as in the Ms.
TEAMS shared folder for your reference.
After the class,
immediately I will upload it there.
That is what I have been practicing and I
will continue to do that.
The quiz assignments,
which are there for the course,
that is the EC1 components,
evaluation component one,
which will run throughout the course.
The dates will be given to you by the
WILP instructions itself shortly,
and I will stick to that schedule.
The other components,
mid sem and comprehensive examination,
I think you would have already got the
dates.
Right,
so this is to answer all your initial
queries. I hope that clarifies.
Your question as well, uh, Sridharan.
Oh, yes, ma'am. Just to confirm, like,
with my understanding,
Thank you.
it's that like we have to be like in
terms of like examinations or anything
that we are preparing for,
we have to make sure like course kind of
these are blueprint kind of thing,
whatever the topics that have been
mentioned that like we have to be
specific to that only.
It's yeah.
Okay, okay, man.
Thank you.
Okay, so with that,
I'll get into today's topic.
So the exam dates should have been
already given to you.
I think there's another question on the
exam dates.
That's another question.
Isn't it not given to you yet?
No, I think I have not received it, ma'am.
So, where do we see it?
Is it through e-mail?
It should be there in your homepage
itself when you log into your e-learn.
But subject-wise,
I think it should have been shared with
you. If not,
I will get it for this course and share
it with you.
OK, Sharma.
So usually it is around 8 weeks.
So after 8 weeks, we will have the,
so this is our second week, right?
So after 8 weeks,
we will have the mid-semester examination.
And at the end of 16th week,
that is after the 16th week,
we will have the
comprehensive examination.
So that's how it is.
So I'll get you the exact timetable
shortly.
I'll maybe make our announcements.
Oh, orientation PPT will have it.
That's right, Megha. They might have it.
Yes.
Sure, thank you.
Yeah.
Okay,
so what is Software Development Life
Cycle?
This is what we started our previous
session as well.
But I will reframe the question,
what will happen if we don't follow SDLC?
Why,
why should we follow our Development Life
Cycle?
To build a software.
Ma'am,
if we don't follow a definite process
like HDLC,
then we cannot stick to schedule.
You know,
every component will run independently
and there will be no end goal, right?
So one can start the requirement,
someone can start testing while the
development is still on.
So there has to be a process or
methodology that has to be followed.
so that software is developed and
deployed as per schedule and on time.
Right, exactly.
So I have a few answers in the chat.
All of them are exactly on point.
So to track.
to plan and execute within that planned
timeline to avoid any last minute
bottlenecks or errors,
to standardize the entire process so we
don't have to have some miscommunications
among all the other team members or when
we are working in a team.
A process gives us a life cycle,
a methodology gives us a way to execute
well to avoid.
many things leading to conflicts, yes.
So all your answers are right.
So we are having a software development
lifecycle.
Um...
to actually deliver a software.
The goal always is to create and deploy a
high quality software.
So when I say high quality,
it's not just that.
which is something with fancy features.
When I say quality, it includes security,
reliability.
so that they can trust the application in
terms of the data plus.
It will be up and running all the time,
makes it wrong.
So, the goal is to...
Deliver.
And we don't want a bottleneck.
We don't want an error.
We don't want any miscommunications.
and we want to deliver on time.
So for all that,
we need a Development Life Cycle,
a proper planning,
and we have to follow that life cycle.
Sorry, I had a bloody bad throat today.
So what are the models we have heard of?
The software,
all these are software Development Life
Cycle models.
So this is the first model all of us
would have heard of,
either theoretically or you would have
experienced it.
It has been practiced somewhere.
Or at least you would have heard of,
right?
So what is the problem with this
waterfall modeling?
So once requirements are fixed,
so they will know get back to the
I want.
previous and we can't go it further.
So once the fix will follow the same bill,
Yes.
all the phases, ma'am.
Exactly. So it's a linear approach.
That is,
Stack you.
you want everything at the beginning.
And each phase depends on the previous
one.
You don't have an option of going back
and revisiting the previous step at all.
So the sequence is followed right from
requirements, design, development, test,
deploy, maintenance.
In which each phase must be completed
before the next one begins.
Each phase is based on an assumption.
that there were no errors in the previous
phase and you will it is like
traditionally you take a lock and lock
that phase.
There is no option to go back and open
that phase at all.
So once the previous phase is over,
the developers quickly get to work.
in the next phase, et cetera.
It's a very straightforward,
easy to manage approach,
which is idle for small projects,
which has well-defined roles and
responsibilities where you have all the
requirements in hand.
But the problem is when we don't have the
requirements, it's not a project which is,
it's a simple one where we have all the
requirements plus we.
We cannot freeze the requirements that is.
The changes cannot be adapted or that if
you have a software.
which requires changes.
You cannot use waterfall at all.
Do you think we have any software in
today?
Which has which can be implemented with
the waterfall.
Think of something as simple as...
A small application.
Are there anything which can be
implemented with waterfall today?
Man, for banking implementations,
I think still waterfall is followed.
Is right,
because we are they are bounded by
compliance and regulations which cannot
undergo change during that period,
at least.
Of Development.
Right.
But what if the banking themselves?
There is a compliance change now,
now that because of there are a lot of
security vulnerabilities are there.
Even the government and the compliance
authorities are trying to revisit.
If there is something which is changing,
then again, waterfall is a.
So now, that's a very interesting point,
I think. Is it Gurdik who said that?
Yes, ma'am.
Right? Yeah, because I have two,
three panels,
so sometimes I miss who actually spoke.
Sorry for that. So now...
So you are talking about requirements
changing only, right?
What if there is something which is
changing in the,
say only in the implementation you see
that the design itself is a flaw or there
is something problem with the design only
when you implement?
Stack.
So that also is not possible.
When we say change,
waterfall cannot adapt to change,
we immediately, intuitively,
all of us meant the requirements change,
right?
But there are changes in the design phase
also,
which are implementation or something.
happening during the deployment,
we realized, okay,
this is not how it should have been
implemented.
So waterfall does not have a way to
revisit the previous spaces,
not only the requirement space.
That was the major problem.
And that is where a few evolutions
started.
happened.
So one of the earlier evolutions of the
waterfall is the B model.
It's a evolution of the classic waterfall
methodology itself,
but a slight verification and validation
phase where the phases were executed in a
sequential V shape.
So the V doesn't stand for validation or
verification, but the V shape.
The waterfall.
And the model as such,
while easy to manage and control,
it did not allow for any flexibility with
customer change requests and whatever
requests in terms of developers, etc.
And the time to market was very high.
And whenever you find a problem.
If you find a problem as early,
the time to fix it is also easier,
but when you find the problem only in the
later phase,
if you have a problem in design.
you identify it in implementations,
it's still quite easier to solve it.
But if you have a problem in design which
you have found it in the last phases of
testing, then you have to redo the entire.
implementation efforts, et cetera.
So we needed a model which focuses on
testing. That is, when I say testing,
it's not the unit testing or the
traditional testing.
It is testing means verification and
validation at each stage of development.
So every phase in the development process
has a corresponding testing phase,
ensuring that validation and verification
are performed consistently.
The V in the name, as I mentioned,
does not reflect validation and
verification, but describe
how the two things,
that is the process and the verification
are conducted in parallel,
and then they take the project to a
single completion point.
The point corresponds to the
implementation phase where the coding
Bigots.
What this will achieve?
What do you think this will achieve
compared to waterfall model?
Forget our latest models, iterative.
They are all much better than the V model,
but I think you just are in the phase
that classical waterfall was there and
then V came in.
What do you think would have?
would have been the benefit.
Teams can work independently, yes.
The testing,
when you say teams can work independently,
the requirements team and the acceptance
testing, that is what they can work.
Still,
design cannot happen before the
requirements phase is closed.
So it's not completely loosely coupled,
but to a certain extent better than the
team.
Working for.
Defects can be cached much,
much earlier rather than propagated.
Right, yes, that is the first the defects.
can be identified at an early stage.
Right, so that is the idea,
but what do you think will be the
downside of this?
And this could be more time taking.
Right, and of course, yes.
Anything else?
Still,
I think the testing would be limited to
individual functionalities,
but on a broader integrated,
the full end-to-end testing will still
not be possible.
Yes, time consuming, yes.
And it is the scope is defined to that
particular phase.
So you might be iterating between those
two steps itself because of the
verification and validation.
Right,
so you will not proceed to the next phase,
which is again,
and it is a resource consuming,
as Karthik has mentioned,
that is also right.
And another thing is it,
when it is applied to think of a complex
applications, enterprise applications,
et cetera, you are come exactly, SINDHURA,
you are testing without something in hand,
you are testing on the requirements again
and again, you are validating.
But they don't,
you are going back to the customer or
you're going back to the design team
testing,
but you don't see any progress further.
So it when it is an ERP kind of,
so not ERP, enterprise systems.
there is a possibility or large systems
or complex systems,
there is a possibility the entire process
becomes a little cumbersome and because
of the frequent changes and the
validations which are happening.
So that was the V model, right?
All this were majorly the waterfall era.
Then came the agile. Agile,
or I would say the iterative model, right?
So before the name agile,
the manifesto came in and all.
When I say agile,
I'm referring to all the iterative and
incremental models. Okay,
so basically all this incremental and
iterative models,
they attempted to establish a agile as
well as an adaptive framework. So here...
The agile methodology,
basically it takes a very flexible,
iterative approach.
It focuses on customer.
customers are put first.
It takes the customer feedback seriously
and they try to collect customer feedback
as early as possible.
It emphasizes collaboration.
adaptability and
So how does this achieve that is all the
iterative models,
they divide the project into small
manageable iterations.
And each iteration has something or some
version of the software coming out of it.
The first version is the minimum viable
product.
the MVP. So that's how it comes out of it.
Something comes out of it, right?
So at each iteration,
the software is tested.
It is again refined based on the feedback
until the final product meets all the
requirements.
So that is the iterative model.
So Agile takes a very flexible approach.
The focus here, if you take on Agile,
continuous evaluation.
In V model also, the evaluation,
the validation and verification was given
emphasize, but not in the right direction.
Here, the evaluation was given.
So changes in the direction can be made
easily, changes if there are any.
And it has a better control of scope,
time, and resources,
as well as early detection of technical
or architectural issues.
But...
What was the problem with Agile?
Anyone remember initial stages when it
started,
before the Scrum and the Kanban
approaches were taken up?
What do you think would have been the
problem when this iterated development
would have started?
Maybe frequent changes in the decision,
just because it's like, or we can go.
No, there is no frequent decisions.
You don't change anything for that sprint.
You just have this twist,
you go through it, and then you come back.
Right?
I don't think frequent changes might be
if there is was not good understanding on
how the sprint was designed and fixed.
But I don't see that as a problem with
the framework.
It might have happened in a few places
where it was there.
Version control was not proper.
Version control of the software,
you're saying?
I think it posed a risk of lot of rework
also.
because I have the experience,
like I work in on the banking side,
Right.
so I have been in few core banking
implementations.
So when we go with the iterative model,
for example,
we first go live with the customer,
we first do the customer.
Go like that. OK,
we have we have taken up the customer's
data. Later,
we go with the accounts till the customer
is going live.
We account is in subscription mode.
Once we become owner of the accounts,
we we find that OK,
there is a major change in card on the
customer module.
So that requires a rework from scratch
sometimes.
So that is a big challenge that is posed
by the iterative model.
Right.
But that that is going to be a challenge
in waterfall also.
Yes, ma'am. But waterfall,
I think what I have experienced is
usually waterfall,
like the initial requirement phase
extends to last time because, for example,
when I started my career,
Okay.
like the requirement phase went for two,
2 1/2 years,
which is quite a very big time.
But there we...
Open.
We complete all the aspects. So yeah,
like both are pros and cons.
Right.
Yeah,
so basically I would rephrase the problem
which you are saying is the time.
When you say two weeks or shorter time to
market,
you don't give sufficient time to the
requirements to understand the intent of
the customer.
And when you go and show it to the
customer at an early phase,
You understand there is a change and you
have to refactor certain things again
from the beginning,
which is again a rework, et cetera, right?
So that is, yeah, that that is more of a.
Ohh.
I mean,
that's a very real problem which all of
us are facing. I mean,
I think many of the others also
experienced this. But as an agile,
understanding customers,
taking customer feedback is priority.
Right, as a model itself.
What agile brought in or required was a
lot of communication requirements,
that is.
Agile requires careful communication
management,
especially when larger teams are working,
to ensure consistent messaging and
coordination.
Even the same banking example which you
had mentioned,
that Gurdip has mentioned recently.
The communication, what has to be there,
that is where it was lagging.
And of course,
documentation is the other angle of
communication.
How do we ensure that all the 100 plus
team members are there on the same page?
Of course, documentation is the only,
all of us cannot sit on the calls the
entire day instead of doing our work.
So documentation, of course.
has to play a priority.
How do you handle this communication?
Because agile is heavily dependent on the
communication management to ensure that
all of them are in the right track.
Right,
so it follows a more rigid structure with
clearly defined steps focusing only on
incremental improvements,
so it gave a control of.
But how do you?
There is a limited scope for adopting to
the evolving requirements throughout the
project because we know the customers or
as humans also,
even if I am the customer or we are the
customers.
We don't clearly say or we don't
understand what we need in the beginning
itself. So I think Henry Ford,
if I'm not wrong,
Henry Ford once mentioned,
if you go and ask users what they want,
on what vehicle would you before
designing a car, you go ask them.
They will not know what to.
They might say that I would need a high
speed horse.
They will not say that they require a car.
So know you human would
That was the understanding,
that was the actually foundation for all
the user experience or the user study we
are doing today.
So it's very difficult for humans to
imagine what they want in terms of a
software or in terms of a product and
give it to us.
readily like a written document which
will not change at all.
And in waterfall model,
we don't go meet them on a regular basis.
So the only final product goes in.
So they are put to a surprise on what
they want.
But in iterative development,
we are giving them in iterations in agile,
so still they will come up with changes
which are required,
so that's what is the problem we are
having with.
The iterative Development.
Okay,
so before getting into the other models,
What is technical debt?
Have any of you heard of this word
technical in depth?
Yeah.
Yes, PRAJJWAL, go ahead.
Hello, ma'am. Good evening. So,
the technical data,
Good evening.
what comes from the agile methodology,
where we follow sprints to attain a
certain amount of tasks in software
development. So, in sprints,
we always try to cover a few story points,
which are dedicated to each sprint. Say,
assume that we are covering...
8.
Twenty-one story points,
where three features are scheduled to be
shipped in a the desired sprint.
If we say that we could not achieve the
twenty-one story points,
we could only achieve 17 story points,
so the tech tech is of four story points,
which is to be covered in the next sprint.
So,
the technical backlog remaining from the
previous sprint.
which is to be carried out in the
upcoming sprint,
is known as signal target.
OK.
Is that the technical depth?
Any other answers, KAUSIK? Yes, KAUSIK.
Yes, ma'am, good evening. So,
when we see technical debt as a
complexity or complexity introduce for a
particular solution when you are actually
in a building any kind of solution, right?
So,
I mean,
there there could be a possibility that
the complexity increases in order to
achieve certain functionality,
which might have been done a different
way, where you might not need to,
you know,
increase that kind of complexity,
but then how we have implemented.
Because of the implementation,
or to achieve that functionality,
you increase complexities and
dependencies,
so that becomes the technical way in the
in the system.
Right.
Yeah, so basically.
What PRAJJWAL mentioned is what you are
not,
the story points you are not able to
cover in the sprint is something you
carry forward to the next sprint.
That's more of a backlog or you are
redefining the work to be done in the
sprint. Technical depth is...
Not that, actually, so...
I have a few answers also in the.
chat with some of them are right.
Some of them are slightly, I mean,
it's not actually meaning,
it's not entirely wrong,
but it's not conveying the right meaning.
So basically in simple layman terms,
technical depth is a shortcut we take
today to solve that particular problem.
or some optimal, not an optimal decision,
but a suboptimal decision we make during
that particular phase.
It can be called as design.
It can be not only when I say technical,
it can be code depth.
I do a small workaround to solve the
error today, to close that story today,
point today,
or to close that Jira ticket today,
et cetera. But.
It can be a design depth also.
They are all quick fixes we make at that
point in that sprint to just close the
KUMAR closure.
But, if you further, if you look at it,
will lead to more problems in the feature.
So if the error,
so that is what is technical debt,
then that's one of the problems which PRC.
I mean, when I say technical depth,
it includes design process, architecture,
security, then there can be many,
many types of technical depth.
So,
anything which we are making a shortcut
today, or some solution today,
without analyzing or looking at an
optional one which other alternatives
which will give a more optimized solution,
but we are making some with...
fixed today,
which will come as a rework and cost us
more in the future.
So basically when we try, I'll talk,
have a detailed discussion of technical
depth later,
because technical depth is something
which is not only for the agile era,
it is also one of the problems we are
having in the.
AI based SDLC also,
but the technical depth is changed there.
It was a developer who did have timelines,
who did, who has to meet deadlines,
has taken a,
skipped a few best practices or taken a
short.
cut and has done something.
But now what is happening in the
technical depth is we are having AI
producing code at a high velocity and we
don't have sufficient time to manually
test those errors which might result in
technical depth.
in the future.
So that is what technical depth is now
today with the AI thing.
So we will talk about more of that
because that is one of the risk which we
have listed out also.
So we'll have a very detailed discussion,
but I'll just try to clear this point
here.
So, coming to the answers in the...
Chat, um, long delivery gaps. OK,
make now answer was previous AI.
Missed it. Yes,
of course we talked about long delivery
gaps, yes.
And we missed the documentation.
Documentation is a bigger problem of
communication in agile, right?
So technical compromises we do to roll
out future.
in time. That's exactly right.
That is what is a technical depth.
Things which we are not able to squeeze
in the current splint is a backlog.
It's not a technical depth, actually.
It's like a problem.
Right, yes, yes, of course,
technical depth in the AI era is more
dangerous. We have developed.
Ohh.
CHETHAN says we have developed a project,
but it needed some revisit to make it
better. That's exactly right.
We have to spend more time in the future.
Today we have come up with some solution.
Right,
so that always happens with the
assignments also.
At that point in the last 1159,
we want to submit it.
So for the sake of it, we submit it.
But I always get at least 2% of requests
that I have submitted a document and I
feel that I have to do it more.
So then they realize the rubrics and then
come back and ask for an extension or to
submit a document.
So technical depth is there in our
assignments also.
Ma'am,
is legacy system modernization also
counted as technical debt?
Legacy system.
Modernization upgrade or whatever we call
it. Is it also counted as technical debt?
No.
No, that is refactoring, right?
Like we are trying to change,
so that is a new sprint task you will
take it up.
Here you are trying to close something by
doing a shortcut or skipping a best
practice, either because lack of time.
Say for example, I added a feature.
A small change. I ran,
there are a few test cases which are
already run there,
but I ran only two test suits and I
skipped one test suit.
which might result in a technical debt in
the future for me.
Right, so that that's what it is.
OMKAR.
I mean,
that's not that's a that's a very simple
example,
but there are many reasons why technical
depth occurs. We'll discuss more about it.
Okay, thank you.
Okay,
SAURAV has given a more code example. Yes,
a technical depth or code depth is when
you use config password mean as technical
depth.
So you so you are basically not doing
that step and you are using some.
Shortcuts there, right? So,
so the the these things should be
captured by the testing aspects.
As well.
Okay,
so now why did I go to technical dentist?
It's one of the problems in Agile,
and we also see that happening in the AI
era also.
Now.
The spiral,
there are other models also which are in
line with the iterative and incremental
models, spiral model,
rapid system development models,
rapid Application Development.
So all these gained a traction during
some point of time.
by focusing on agility.
to be more customer-centric,
build a minimum viable product,
reduce time to market.
All this things, etcetera, so scrum.
which includes planning, daily meetups,
reviews, demos,
and a retrospective at the end of each
sprint.
The cycle usually lasts for two to four
weeks.
And the scrum is oriented towards
organization of the entire process.
So you have a product owner,
you will have a scrum master,
they do a sprint planning.
Then there's a product backlog you bring
in,
then you attach it as a sprint backlog,
then the team.
works through that for a period based on
your scrum timeline,
then you incrementally add to the product.
So that's one aspect.
Extreme programming targets the technical
side of it.
So I'm not going into those processes,
et cetera, today,
or not in this course in detail.
So when it looked at PARIHAR programming,
it looked at how do you do all these in a
technical aspect, continuous integration,
how do you do,
how do you do test driven development?
How do you look at ways to improve
software quality and responsiveness to
customer needs?
So there are many approaches like PARIHAR
programming, test-driven development,
continuous integration,
which all brought in.
And the Agile Manifesto was written in
2001,
and it became one of the most popular
software development methodology.
because of its more dynamic and iterative
nature.
And you started developing features and
check customer responses before going to
the next step on that.
And then there are many evolutions of
that agile manifesto and methodology.
So there is SAFE,
which is scaled agile framework.
There is large scale.
from all these are various names you will
keep learning.
Think other courses like Software Product
Management and...
you have software architecture might not
cover this.
So I think there is an elective on agile.
So those courses might go into details of
that, et cetera. Okay.
So if there are any more inputs you want,
we will take it up later.
on this agile and other things,
or maybe we can share it as a reading
material, etc.
So the next evolution after agile was the
DevOps evolution.
DevOps,
some people still call it as an agile
methodology only,
where they try to encompass or bridge the
gap between development and operations.
But I personally feel DevOps,
or I have read in many places, that
DevOps is not only a methodology,
it's basically a cultural shift.
Because before DevOps,
if you look at all the problems,
it was termed as a developer problem or
an operations problem.
And there was always pointing the other,
right? And it didn't work out very well.
So it's a major of a cultural shift.
How do you take accountability?
How do you ensure end-to-end delivery?
So if you look at all the SDLC Life Cycle,
which we had described earlier,
it stopped with deployments.
And it.
didn't go about what happened after that,
or even deployment.
I don't know whether it talked about
continuous deployment, etc.
So DevOps was one change.
It enables an end-to-end lifecycle
delivery of features, fixes.
as well as updates and continuous
monitoring.
If the initial agile adoption inherently
stopped or left the operations department
behind, with the deployments.
They focused only on the time to market.
It should, deployment should go,
it should be released fast.
So they were shipping products once a
year, then it became twice a year,
then it become once a month.
Then now I think we are shipping hardly
or daily, 4th night. I remember last time.
When I started the DevOps course or exit,
I think it was around 4th night
deployments done by Netflix.
That's what I read.
So every 14 days we deploy.
That's what they said some few years back.
Now I think they do it on a hourly basis.
The deployments are quick.
so many microservices they deploy on a
daily basis.
Right,
so this trend of to time to faster time
to market that had a lot of problems,
so that needed a rise of a DevOps.
The DevOps came in emphasizing
integration,
continuous integration and continuous
deployment,
which tried to bridge the gap between the
development and the operations team.
So basically,
it's more on collaboration and automation.
Two things is what was the focus of the
entire.
Devos.
Night.
Yeah, you use DevOps, right?
So that's why, yeah, that's exactly right,
Ananda Krishna, as mentioned.
So we don't say DevOps as a methodology,
but that's a major shift after agile.
The major shift was,
that's why I put it as,
I didn't name it as a new SDLC evolution.
But it's a very major impacted shift.
Though we still follow the agile
methodology,
it emphasizes we needed that continuous
integration and continuous deployment
where we focused more on collaboration
and automation.
It's not about the who fast,
who reaches the market faster.
We have to reach.
the market faster with right reliable
software, safe software, right?
So that is where DevOps came in bridging
the gap.
So code changes, it happened quickly,
it happened reliably, it happened safely.
Before DevOps, if you see all the models,
they treat development and operations as
separate phase and there were handoff
points.
The DevOps approach can be applied and
brought in in any, so you can,
it's not that DevOps cannot be applied to.
this methodology or that methodology.
It can be applied to any methodology.
So none of the phases which we are
talking about.
They are no more in silos or production
environments.
So you can have a continuous flow of a
DevOps pipeline, what we call, right,
right from the initial phase to the last
deployment phase.
But what was the challenge with adopting
DevOps?
Many of us would have experienced this.
It needs a lot of tools and software to
carry on proper DevOps,
so that increases the licensing and
technical resources.
M.
Yes, yes, lot of specialized tools.
Upfront investment was required.
Infrastructure.
And qualified staff,
because we know operations is a very
crucial task, right?
And we cannot just hand it over to
someone who's having less experience.
We need qualified staff.
We had to train them.
So that was one of the major problems.
Right, learning curve, exactly right.
Technology was...
Very high,
so we had that time cloud also was
parallelly growing,
so there was a lot of dependency on the
cloud, local infrastructure setting up.
DevOps pipeline on local infrastructure
was a little challenging and then again
we had these vendor lock-in problems.
So these are some of the challenges in
the DevOps setup,
but still today also we are having.
So Pratyush has mentioned something,
hard coding and programs also lead to
technical.
DEEPAK.
Hey.
Right.
Hard coding meant you mentioned some
config parameters, utility programs.
Right. Yes,
that's also not a best practice, right?
We don't hard code values. So for example,
there are five APIs which our front end
has to call.
There should be a separate API config
file which has those endpoints rather
than it being hard coded in the fetch in
the front end.
So yes, that's also a technical depth.
Okay.
So that's on the DevOps.
So now in DevOps also we see.
Continuous integration and delivery falls
under DevOps.
It automates the traditional human
intervention needed to give the...
Product for delivery and deployment,
right? There was a few,
I hope all of you would have heard of
these terms, DevSecOps.
Have you heard of it? DevSecOps.
Yes, ma'am,
so integrating security feature followed
Yes.
by this process.
Yeah,
so not thinking security as an
afterthought,
but also ensuring while we continuously
integrate and continuously deliver,
we also do testing related to security
and validate the product life cycle.
So that is where there's a SecOps because
of.
increased security vulnerabilities,
all this coming into.
Place we had that.
Right, so now we are in the last,
or in this course,
we are going to look at the new change,
the evolution that is on the AI native
and agent tickets TLC,
which is happening right today for the
last few years.
So quick comparison table which I
generated with the gem night.
So, if you look at the waterfall model,
it's more on...
A sequential one, right?
It focuses more on the...
documentation. It takes months to years.
What was the primary
Problem in terms of waterfall model,
which we had been discussing,
is the rigid requirements.
You have to do this and you don't have
options to revisit.
And there is no early feedback because
the customer gets to see it only in the
last few.
phases, upfront planning.
So these were the bottleneck. Right now,
AI can come and impact.
This also, this last three,
I just wrote this impact or
transformation, which, okay,
I'm just not using the pointer right.
So this column,
whatever we are writing is to show that
AI will not only impact agile or scrum
models we are doing today,
but it can impact an waterfall
methodology also by, I mean, it can help.
a few bottlenecks to be eliminated also.
So next is the agile one. So in the agile,
we know that it is more iterative,
more focused on the customer part. It can.
give the primary output which comes out
of it is a shorter sprint work delivered
in terms of iterations to the end user.
So it's more feedback focused, et cetera.
But what are the problems?
I spoke about communication overhead.
because all of us has to be on the same
picture, especially with larger teams.
And context switching is also a problem.
Because your manager or your team lead
prioritizes different stories.
You're working on something,
you want to finish it in the upcoming
sprint,
but suddenly the focus is coming into a
different story point and you completely
have to do a different sprint context.
switching, etc. And of course,
manual story creation.
That was also a problem.
Now we have AI to do that with increased
velocity, right initial PRs, stories, etc.
And then a DevOps.
As I mentioned,
collaboration and automation,
that was the focus.
So continuous integration,
automated deployment,
infrastructure as a code,
that's a very interesting problem many of
us have to understand.
For example,
to replicate the same environment in
development, testing,
and production was itself a major
challenge before DevOps or before
infrastructure as a code.
So how did we ensure that everything had
a same environment and the code executed
in, because always
If you look at a few decades back,
the problem was the code executed well in
the developer environment.
So the developer says, I am done.
It goes to the testing,
testing it doesn't work,
then somehow tester fixes it and makes it
work, tests it and sends it to the.
production then they say the code is not
working.
So,
because the environment itself was
different,
so infrastructure as a code came in where
it was so easy that you can dictate.
clearly how an environment infrastructure
should be line by line without any
deviation.
So that's one of the advantages we have
out of the DevOps, etc.
And the last phase is what is our entire
objective of the course as well.
So how AI is driving all these things in
acceleration?
Intent driven acceleration is what?
It is looking at.
But it is not a smooth path.
As we had bottlenecks in the previous
things,
we are facing bottlenecks in the AI
native SDLC or the AI Augmented SDLC
itself. So what are the problems?
A human AI is developing at one speed,
but we cannot expect humans to verify at
that speed, right?
So there is a gap there.
I remember the pipe we had in the
previous PPT in the previous section.
It's wide open at one end,
but what we have is a process is slower
and smaller pipes in the other end.
Hallucination,
probabilistic output problems.
So these are problems which have happened.
Continuous.
Um...
Code is coming out at a faster pace,
or humans are not able to cope up.
there is something called as slop.
AI's law.
That's a very new term which I got to
know recently.
It's basically low quality, repetitive,
or large amount of content.
Code,
it can be code or it in other in software
development, it's basically code,
but in other cases it can be text or it
can be images, videos, et cetera,
using artificial intelligence created
without.
human intervention or created without
human verification.
mass produced articles,
but not given any human touch to it.
So that is a bigger problem we have today.
So we have so many codes,
the PRs are increasing,
but who approves the PR?
That is the problem, right?
So all your junior developers or all who
are...
working. You ask them to ship a feature,
they give it to AI,
they are all giving you new features.
add it to the application and they just
put it in the request. But who?
It is us who have to manually verify the
PR, the human.
And I say us humans have to manually
verify it and then accept it, right?
So that is where the problem comes in,
in terms of.
the AI era which we are looking at.
So how do we look at this?
How are we going to manage this?
What are the ways in which we can
automate certain things?
That is what is going to be our
discussions. In every phase,
we are going to look at how this can be.
So the primary output is autonomous
feature, automatically AI giving us, say,
I'm running a e-commerce application,
I say I want a new feature,
AI automatically gives that and it is
deployed to production.
That is what we are,
that is the error or that is the thing we
are looking at,
but that's not practically.
possible today without human in the loop,
but how do we ensure that human in the
loop also is done in a more real in that
is what whatever is possible in reality?
So that is what we are going to.
Look at, and this also is going to shift.
how we are going to see developers, right?
So earlier developers were focusing more
on building things, writing code,
looking at architecture,
looking at the code,
more cleaner code options, etc.
But now they are more into orchestrating
and reviewing.
Please.
Right.
Okay, so now we spoke about SDLC,
evolution of SDLC, all that.
Right, so now tell me.
I started this class with a question,
what will happen if you don't have SDLC?
Right. So now since we have AI.
Do you still think this DLC is relevant?
Yes.
Yes, yes, ma'am.
Yes.
Is still SDLC relevant? Yes.
Yes, ma'am.
Yeah.
Right,
so all of us agree that still we need a
life cycle.
Right.
But the faces.
will change. So maybe the,
so when I say the phases will change,
say I did design this amount of time,
I did coding this amount of time,
I did testing this amount of time. So my,
some of these phases might shrink.
Right,
and some of these spaces might extend.
So this first SDLC, which I did,
might not be the same as the second SDLC
I'm going to do today.
So these spaces are going to shrink and
expand as per the needs and as per the
problems and as per the programs.
But what is going to stay intact in the
SDS itself? Thank you.
Okay.
Now, one basic question, leave AI. OK,
AI is going to,
I made a comment that AI can be applied
to any SDLC model,
even if it's waterfall or agile or etc.
But generally, just a.
Question to understand your.
How,
how well you have understood the SDLC
models.
What SDLC model?
How will you choose what SDLC model is
suitable for your project?
Can you name some factors you will
consider?
To choose which model,
what are the factors you will look at?
Time to market.
Okay.
And how will we do the requirements?
I think these two factors are very
important.
Okay,
so you will look at whether we have the
complete requirements or we have
incremental requirements,
Okay.
how well we know the requirements.
So that will be a deciding factor and how
much time I have to reach the market.
It's size and complexity,
that's a very interesting point.
So what is the project size?
If it's a very big project,
I will not take risk of a waterfall model.
And the complex, how complex it is, right?
Yes, stakeholders availability. That is,
when I say stakeholders availability,
I'm putting it in a single term like
Theme structure, right?
So we look at project size,
complexity of the project,
timelines we have, requirements,
frequency,
that is how often we have to shift to
market, etc.
OK, OK,
so now I'll give you some parameters.
I have a large,
complex project that requires...
Frequent changes.
and also close collaboration with.
Multiple stakeholders.
Okay, large,
complex project requires frequent changes
and close collaboration with multiple
stakeholders.
So which model should I choose? Agile,
I already see answers.
Ajay.
If I ad.
I would also need long-term maintenance.
And.
I also say that it requires deployment in
larger cycle than it is DevOps also.
When I say only large project or a
complex project, frequent changes.
Then it is agile,
but if I focus on long-term maintenance,
continuous integration, and deployment,
it directly moves to DevOps plus agile,
right?
If it's a very small,
time-limited project.
with well-defined requirements.
What will we choose?
Waterfall.
Not a problem.
waterfall, right?
Well-defined requirements,
The.
minimal client involvement, limited time,
we can go for waterfall.
Say there is a time-limited project.
But requirements are not very clear.
You have to continuously validate,
then we go for the.
V shape model.
So these are some basic things. Of course,
in reality, that doesn't happen. Today,
all of us go over shipping.
Mostly go with the agile plus DevOps only.
And now with AI,
AI is DLC is what is being followed.
But this is for us to understand.
This is what had happened in the past.
Okay.
May I have a question?
Yes, yeah, go ahead.
What if I want to work on a gile model or
a DevOps,
but the stakeholder from the client side
who also has to get involved in the
development of the module of their part,
they are on waterfall. So in that case,
we can have stakeholders, right,
who are operating on different
stSemAIMLstudentsdocs.
In a single project.
Right.
So, so in that case,
how how to I don't know that like what
what is the best usually because within
my project I have seen that my like my
product team used to work on user story
basis that every every friend they would
create user stories because they have a
product type and product roadmap also and
accordingly they.
They will take up user stories and and
deliver,
In.
but but the but the but the teams from
the client side,
they they worked on a different mode and
it usually, you know,
created a timeline gaps.
What they want may suppose today,
as per the product roadmap,
it will be delivered maybe two months
from now.
Okay.
So,
so that those frictions have come up very
frequently.
Yeah, of course, yes, fictions are there.
I mean,
it's a very complicated thing only.
But in reality,
I have also seen a few cases internally
also in the WILP bits when we had to work
with a few other.
IT vendors, etc.,
or work with in collaboration with
campuses and industries.
All of them have different aspects.
There are still, like,
we have still a few legacy systems, right,
which they don't come out of it, etc. So.
Um...
What, again,
the collaboration is something which is
very important then.
They can adapt spiral, agile,
waterfall to match their unique workflows.
But what is the point of communication?
What are the signing off?
What are the major milestones?
That has to be clearly defined.
Like, so, um...
That is where we can eliminate the
friction at some point in time.
So if your stakeholders are working at
certain things, so you should,
the documentation as such waterfall is
heavy documentation.
So if they are even working on a
waterfall model,
is they are clearly documenting and they
don't deviate from what is there in the
PRD.
Then you, if we go by that PRD,
which is what we are also doing slightly
in spec driven Development,
I think we will not have a major problems.
You go by it,
you have some placeholders until their
product comes in. And that's how it works.
actually works.
But handoffs as well as the signing of
points should be very well defined.
And.
Even if that is the case,
I do understand there will be a lot of
friction.
There will be a lot of problems also.
So you would have faced certain things.
I can easily say you have to define the
signing off and handoffs,
whatever is required.
We define the checkpoints,
but still there will be problems in terms
of by the time they come back,
there will be,
with the technologies changing rapidly,
there can be a few things which might not
even work today,
which has worked like two months back.
I mean, those are the real problems.
We have faced,
especially in the supply chain libraries,
we had a few problems in the past.
So they, the other thing, the legacy,
they were,
we had told them that we will be
migrating to one of the latest libraries.
and we had gone to them and then here the,
so they went and changed their aspect of
it. They were ready,
but here the library didn't work well or
it had a newer upgraded version or
something happened and they ended up in
the same place.
So such problems do exist.
Anyone else would like to add a few more?
I, I saw hand raised, yes, but you got it.
Yeah, ma'am,
can you please help me distinguish
between the iteration model in Agile
versus the CICD in DevOps?
I'm not able to distinguish between them.
Okay,
so agile is when you stop at the early
stages of agile. Don't think as...
DevOps is a new methodology.
It's an extension of Agile where we
started focusing on the continuous
integration,
bridging the gap between development and
operations. So before,
when Agile was there,
it focused only on the development
lifecycle part and once the product is
ready tested,
It was passed on to the operations team.
The deployments not taken care much,
or there was no much of planning,
or it was left to the deployments team.
This came,
this brought in the rise of DevOps.
So I will not see Agile as separate,
DevOps as separate.
When you focus only on the...
Till the deployment part,
so if you go back to the diagram.
So when you stop here.
This part that is where agile stops,
right? But then DevOps came and...
It bridged or reduced the gap between
operations as well as development team.
And agile is now being practiced at all
phases, including operation, monitoring,
continuous integration, and deployment.
So that is how I would say it's not a
different model as such agile and develop.
Okay, ma'am, thank you.
Right,
so that is that is one part of your
question.
What was the other part of your question?
No, that was pretty much it.
Okay.
Did I miss anything on the chat?
Agile plus DevOps.
Ma'am,
I just have one more query on this
diagram like you have mentioned for
DevOps, right? So generally after testing,
we will do the deployment, right?
Like you have mentioned release.
So just wanted to understand.
Sorry, after testing, we will do.
We would do the deployment, right?
Like we would deploy to production or
something like that.
And then we would have the release, right?
Okay.
Yes, so, so that's what is the difference.
So,
Yeah, we do.
what is the difference between continuous
integration and continuous deployment?
Or continuous, sorry,
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment.
Sorry, ma'am, I didn't get you.
OK, so when we say continuous.
delivery and continuous deployment,
they differ by approval and full
automation for production releases.
So ideally what we do,
we package our test, say I have a product,
okay, I completely test it.
And then I hand it over to our operations
team by manual approval, right?
Continuous delivery requires a human
intervention to release changes live,
while continuous deployment is something.
You have different production
environments.
There is only a verification take by the
DevOps or whoever is responsible for it.
But it goes straight to production.
There is a pipeline,
a deployment pipeline.
Which makes it go directly to the
production,
so delivery stops at the previous at the
acceptance test,
so that is why the release here when does
not released.
to production environment,
it is like a handoff to the client or the
customer.
Okay, okay, got it.
So when you say production,
there is only one more step.
That is you give it to your stakeholder,
but it is not lying.
That one step of production deployment is
pending there.
Okay.
OK,
sometimes we might we might have a human
intervention here,
but in continuous deployment we might not
even have if say we directly push it to
the deployment,
it it it is deployed to all.
Users,
or we might follow different deployment
patterns. No, we have different patterns,
like blue-green deployment.
There are different deployment strategies.
Maybe if you are doing DevOps,
you will learn it in detail.
I'm just giving you a simple example.
Say I want...
Say today Netflix decides or even
WhatsApp is doing this.
I don't know how many of you noticed.
One day I'm seeing status arranged
vertically for some period of time in the
morning and the other day I'm seeing
again the status coming in horizontally.
Did you all notice any one of you?
Yes, ma'am. Yeah,
initial version couple of months back,
What's that?
yes, that was there. Now, currently, yes,
we are seeing in horizontal only, yeah.
Good.
Yeah, so it keeps shifting, right?
So that they're testing.
Probably they had done this to a few set
of users.
So usually when a new feature is coming
up,
they will do a blue-green kind of a
deployment.
They will deploy to a certain set of
users, see how it is working.
They don't have major problems, et cetera.
Then they will.
move it to a bigger crowd,
or they will release it for a certain
amount of time, they will roll back.
So these are deployment things which will
be carried out. So again, there are a,
yeah, the AB testing, that's also right.
So you'll get to learn all this in detail
in the DevOps course.
I think you'll have an introduction to
DevOps course, which you might have.
Miss Naveen,
next time we say we have that coming.
Yes, so you will get into the detail.
So, MLOps, I Abhinav's question. So,
when you DevOps was focused initially,
again,
and I've according to me my personal
opinion, it's all new names,
attractive names to build new
designations and payrolls, etcetera,
but practically, how do you?
like DevOps to softwares which include AI
models. So when you have a software,
a simple,
let's take a simple e-commerce software
which didn't have the AI aspect.
It has only a back end, front end.
It might have a database persistent layer,
et cetera. So we talked about,
when we talk about DevOps,
we are talking about that.
But when a software included a
recommendation engine,
when it had a chat bot inside it,
et cetera,
it became a software which had a AI model
or a ML model inside it, so...
There is a lot of data engineering you
have to do. Also manage those AI models.
Software engineering for ML is a little
different.
You cannot follow the traditional.
Our databases are not same as or our
backend are not same when it comes to AI.
Right, you need a deeper understanding,
you need more continuous monitoring,
etcetera. So,
when a software application involves
machine learning models plus other things,
machine learning artifacts, etcetera,
that is when they called it as...
ML Ops and now you see they call it as AI
Ops.
Because it involves agents.
So,
how do you do the DevOps practices for ML?
For when it includes only a model ML
models or when it included only software,
it was called DevOps, then ML Ops.
Now we have AI Ops,
so that's how it is changing.
Of course, the what they do.
is also changing technically,
but the conceptually it is the same.
We want to have a continuous delivery and
continuous integration pipeline.
That is the ultimate goal.
That's the difference.
Yes,
Guru Raj's question may I large complex
systems with limited client end user
involvement.
Uh,
which model waterfall might be used in
this case, as yes, uh, Ayushmita has sent,
uh, but it also.
varies probably if see if it's a aviation
or ISR project,
the requirements is also going to come
internally, right?
So I would not completely say waterfall
model.
So again and again we are going back to
the same intuitive mindset, right?
By default when we say.
things are changing when iterated.
We are only talking about the
requirements change which is happening
from the customer side. But all of us,
when we are developing software,
there are changes which are happening in
design. But only when we do testing,
we identify a few problems in design.
So we should have an iteration.
There only OK, so.
So that is where the problem will come in.
OK, so if you look at rapid application,
rapid prototype developments, etc.
You will have this.
That is my good.
So this requirements phase will freeze,
but there will be an iteration happening
between these three phases continuously.
Design, implementation, testing,
and then it goes for deployment.
So multiple cycles will happen here only,
because only when you test,
you will understand there are problems
with design.
etc. and all.
So to answer Gururaj's question, yes,
waterfall can be followed because the
requirements will not change.
They have understood the ultimate goal,
etc. But changes can happen in testing,
design phase, implementation, testing,
etc.
Only the customer requirements might not
change.
OK.
OK,
there is a little confusion between
release versus deployment.
Release is something when you have a.
It involves, it's not only technical, it,
there is a cuement, there is a sign off,
hand off. I finish this work,
you give a chip, that is the transaction.
When you complete your transaction,
you give, okay, proceed.
The final OTP when you give and proceed,
right? So you.
You do a go ahead.
So the manager or someone sits on the
client side, acceptance just is done.
They say release this product,
we are all satisfied.
That is what is a release means, right?
The UAT is also includes that.
Deployment is more in technical in nature.
Where we are now in DevOps,
we are looking at more of a continuous
deployment.
Like,
we are looking at ways in which anything
you change in production directly goes to
the VIVEK.
So deployment is something where we
ensure that our software,
whatever we change,
is available on all environments, server,
cloud, device, execution, everywhere.
And the new feature is...
Available, right?
These terms are, in reality,
we use them interchangeably, right?
But deployment is technical in nature,
releases.
The UAT is also completed.
The customer has given official go ahead.
You have done some AB testing on what
other testing.
and the software is made available to end
users or customers.
It is available for consumption.
That is when release comes.
So,
release is something very important is.
Because the versioning changes,
documentation,
it is going to the outside world, right?
It has crossed all of all your internal
checkpoints, etc.
Still there also we have release rollback
strategies,
but deployment rollback strategies are
less.
will be different and release load back
strategies will be completely different.
Right, so that that is what it is.
The timing there, that is the difference.
And in practice, we have a human go ahead.
In the release,
deployments are more automated in nature
as of today.
Actually,
I had planned to finish this in one hour,
but it actually gone a little above hands,
but that's okay.
We'll have time to pop up. So now,
What are the key things which are?
enabled the model, SDLC model to evolve.
Today we are having the change because of
our technology.
destruction happening because of AI.
But over the years,
always our goals have been,
why did we move from waterfall to the
model, or why did we move from V to agile,
etc.?
It was all these factors.
And we are going to look at all these
factors again and again to improve our
process slowly.
So always we wanted to have a faster time
to market.
We wanted to incorporate feedback,
reduce cost and risk.
productivity,
enhanced quality and security without no
downtime, automated updates to software.
So remember we used to get a mail,
now rarely, even ERP and all I remember.
We used to get emails that today it will
not be available. So I used to go check,
do we have any deadlines scheduled for
today? So it should be changed,
extend all that.
But now we hardly get such downtime
emails, right? Hardly,
even if you get it is.
for hour or less than that.
Earlier we used to get one day of
downtime, etc. Now we don't get those,
right? Automate more automation,
developer skill shortage. So this is,
these are the.
Areas which always have.
evolution has happened because of these
factors. And we are also seeing...
And that the AI evolution is also
happening because of all these factors in
the software model.
So.
To summarize.
What are the shift? Just give me a second.
There is some problem in the PPT.
So we will quickly go through.
I have written a few changes which is
happening in SDLC. Okay.
This we will be anyway revisiting,
but I'm just giving us to discuss the
problems because our next goal would be
to discuss what are the
the risk involved in using AI in SDLC and
also the risk,
how do we understand those risks,
what are the nature of the risk, etc.
So I have listed down how AI has impacted
every major phase in SDLC. Okay.
So if you look start with the
requirements and architecture phase,
what we do in the traditional approach,
the product manager writes a
documentation, requirements documentation,
PRD document,
architect designs and API endpoints.
Manually, the developer, they develop it.
They write it over, they design it,
or they may create a architecture
diagrams, all that over the weeks, right?
So now what is happening or what is
possible with AI, right?
I'm not saying this is happening
seamlessly. Okay, Paul,
please don't take that. Today we are.
able to do that.
There are many problems in doing this.
That is what our modules are going to
talk about.
But what is possible today is whatever
discussions the product manager had with
all the stakeholders.
They can easily get converted into an
open API specifications or a PRD document.
The design can be done in a span of
minutes. The AI agents can provide.
the architectural diagram,
the specifications at a faster pace.
So this is possible in SDLC in the first
phase.
Right, and anything else is possible.
Apart from this.
Did I miss anything else?
All of you,
do you agree that this is possible?
I mean, the quality, we will leave it.
We'll talk about what problems it brings
in,
but do you all agree that today it is
possible to do this in a span of minutes,
right, with AI?
Now, if you go to the development phase,
earlier developers were writing first,
they took some time to set up the
environment, create the boilerplate,
and then write code,
then write unit tests, etc. Now,
we have co-pilots and...
agents to write that.
So,
and they can do it parallelly in our
environment,
parallelly doing on a single task prompt.
So this is also possible today.
In the testing phase also,
we used to spend a lot of time on quality
assurance test engineers, test managers,
they used to spend a lot of time planning
for the testing,
how do they want to test it,
what all phases they should test, how
Quantum of how much quantum they should
test, etc. now.
You have options to write test cases
through LLMs. They can.
give you the data of how much code is
covered, how much is undetected,
what are the edge cases.
You can write unit tests or you can write
any kind of testing scripts with AI
agents. You can create. I recently read,
I think in Jira, if I'm not wrong.
They have.
Created an AI agent where it can only
assign,
take a PR request or take a Jira ticket,
look at the problem, correct it,
and apply it.
So that's how they have developed.
So AI agents automatically can locate the
problems and they can fix it or they can
even write tests for it. Right now comes.
when it comes to review and governance.
PR code reviews usually used to take a
lot of time.
And.
Then we also had a lot of security flaws
being missed out,
edge cases due to fatigue or at some
point in time when we were shipping at a
faster phase,
where code reviews didn't happen.
It was missed, all these are there.
And today we have.
options to do that in an automated
fashion with AI.
So you can have tools to do regression
testing,
to check for architectural pattern
violations,
to check for security vulnerabilities on
that. And in the last phase,
which is on the operations and incidents,
which I was telling about AI Ops.
That's what they are saying today.
ML Ops or AI Ops.
In the traditional approach, engineers,
they have to find out the bug.
There was 2 factors. Mean time to recover.
Like, how much, if you identify a failure,
what is the recovery time and what are
the self-healing options we had, right?
So, that is how we were looking at,
so Kubernetes or the early stages of...
containerization,
the orchestration engine,
they were all working towards how do you
have a self-healing system.
So something goes down,
how do you bring it up automatically,
monitor it.
I always want to maintain 20 instances of
these microservice running means.
I always had more.
continuously I was focusing on the logs
and I was always ensuring that 20
instances of micro services was running.
And if one instance goes out also,
my orchestration engine immediately
spawns in a new micro services so that I
don't have any.
loss.
That is how we were working in the
traditional approach. Now,
that work is also can now be done through
AI. You can look at the feedbacks,
the logs, etc., see what error.
analyze the root cause, summarize it.
But this is an area which is not explored
much compared to the first four phases
yet because of certain risks involved and
the lack of...
technical advancements in this particular
area. So now, with this fairly...
All of you have an idea what is SDLC,
what is how SDLC evolved,
and how AI can transform every phase of
SDLC, right? So our next job.
Is to look at.
What are the shifts which have happened
majorly?
I have listed down 5 shifts.
You can of course go through that.
But having understood these changes,
what are the major shifts?
I have listed five major shifts,
which I'm going to discuss in detail.
So probably today I will discuss only one.
In next class,
we will discuss all the four.
But, before that...
Do we have any other major shift we are
seeing because of the AI in the entire
software engineering software Development
Life Cycle?
Leave the problems, okay?
We'll discuss problems later,
but what is the shift?
So a few shift I have written here.
Then effort is no longer the bottleneck,
right?
Because we are generating code at a
higher speed.
Roles are less siloed. That is,
you are not expecting a project product
manager to only give you PRD document.
Now with AI,
they can give you a MVP as well.
Right, so there is a little blur in roles.
Now,
we cannot say that I will not change this.
I cannot go back.
The change is hard to make at this point
in time because with the refactoring,
with code being generated at a faster
phase and in a cheaper way.
There can be any decisions we can roll
back or we can go and do the changes.
Accountability is becoming a more foggier
or not very clear when AI authors certain
things who should take accountability.
outcomes are not deterministic anymore,
they are probabilistic, not guaranteed.
So these are the shifts.
Okay,
so first we will have a discussion of all
these shifts,
understand a few with few examples.
And then in the next phase,
we can go and look at some shifts,
which are each of these shifts,
what are the examples,
and then we will see how what are the
risks these shifts are bringing in.
So any other shift which you think I have
missed out here?
Cost unpredictability,
that's a very good point,
because we are not able to estimate the
token, the number of tokens,
because of the probabilistic nature and
non-deterministic one,
how the AI models behave.
We are not able to
Predict the past.
When I'm about to ship a product and when
I'm almost on the close of completing the
feature, I said my token usages.
maxed out, right? Yes,
that's a very important.
And it has given us a lot of uncertainty
in terms of cost.
Definitely, yes.
OK, Kumar, Ashutosh, yeah,
I'll just read out within a minute.
Um...
Ohh, sorry.
I'll just finish this chat.
Accessibility of knowledge base be
considered as a manage major shift, okay?
Accessibility of knowledge base.
Everyone has access to knowledge.
So is that a major shift?
Earlier also we had open source, right?
I actually didn't get the intent.
Maybe if you can explain it by unmuting,
that would be better.
Yeah, hi, Kumar here.
Like what I mean by knowledge base was
Yes.
like previously we used to source through
the open source,
the web platforms to understand the
practices or like how we need to
Okay.
implement the requirements.
But now we can like.
Just ask, and like, uh,
we can get the complete thing over the AI
itself, so...
Okay,
so that's an advantage we are saying.
Yeah, that could get an advantage, yeah.
Are you saying it's an advantage or it
could be both advantage and disadvantage
also?
Yeah, AI could be unpredictable, yeah.
Like,
I mean, what is it?
I understood like earlier we used to like
put much of an effort and it was a manual
thing to like go through and browse
through the documentation and everything.
So yeah, I think if.
Okay, so basically, can I put it this way,
like the learning curve or the time the
developer or anyone has to spend in
acquiring the skills to do that task is
reduced.
That's a major shift is what you're
saying.
Is is that right?
Yes.
Yes, yes, okay.
Okay.
Definitely, yes.
Okay,
so GURURAJ says workload reduction on the
developer.
Development can save themselves from
extended office hours as well.
That is definitely right. The pressure,
the neck holding for the developer has
completely reduced now, right?
But again, as AAYUSMITA has mentioned.
Writing my own code and verifying it is
much better than verifying the hundreds
of lines written by AI. I actually,
we all experienced that, right? So you...
Right,
the same time is spent in reviewing and
testing, right?
What is expected out of a developer is
changed,
but as it given some free time to the
developer, I'm not sure.
It depends on organization to
organization and people to people, right?
You really miss the waterfall model. Yes,
all developers miss the waterfall model
because we cannot lock that requirement
space, right? But customers are...
Customer should always be the first
priority, right?
Very true.
Effort estimation patterns changing.
ANUPAM, can you please explain that like?
So I think what is also happening is
because AI can do a certain amount of
coding,
it can also do reviews and it can do
certain other things, right?
Now earlier we knew that this much of
time is needed by a human, right?
Now when your AI is augmenting some of
that part,
We are not really sure how much is that
improvement, right? So,
because it's an integrated thing,
but AI kind of we have to keep prompting
with the right prompts and have to see
review and all of that,
all I mean it does save,
but that pattern is not very clear as of
now, how much it saves,
so when you estimate a project.
Yes.
This is an issue at this time, I think.
Definitely, that's exactly right.
So how much of AI they are leveraging on,
how much they are not leveraging on? Yeah,
how do you bill the clients for ours?
Especially companies which were billing
based on ours,
I think that's a major blow there.
How do you estimate?
The efforts, right?
Yeah.
Very true, very true, yes.
Cost is something we have to discuss in
detail.
Spend-driven Development has gained
importance. That's exactly right.
Documentation has become more,
much more important.
So I'm going to explain the importance of
doc.
Dev effort is no longer the bottleneck,
that's true,
but the effort is in terms of...
the importance of documentation,
how well you document it,
because earlier at least you had humans
who are reading that and using it to be
on the same lines.
But now there are going to be missions
who are doing that.
So the documents have to be much more
prioritized and be right.
The amount of code in the PR is becoming
massive. Accountability is reduced.
That's exactly right.
That's what we are going to discuss in
one of these shifts as well. True. Yes.
As we are discussing more inclusion of AI,
it might affect the security domain.
Okay,
so you're worried about the access to the
data and the application?
Which goes to the models, when,
especially when you use external models,
is that what uh,
so when you say you're especially when
Yes, yes, ma'am.
you're using external models, uh,
that's where you are a little worried,
right?
Oh, ma'am,
it's just that like I was trying to say
is like there is one project I'm like,
we are trying to bring in is that like,
whatever the projects we have in the
organization,
we just try to bring up some links
between them like here and there like
there would be something like we have.
So here, sometimes the organization
like they restrict us from using most of
the data to create a agent or to create a
more, what do you say this,
details like you would need about the
projects in organization itself.
And still they restrict us from the data
which they think that it might compromise
the security. So here, like we are.
talking about the process that how the
shifts have been done, right? Like, sorry,
what are the shifts that we could see,
right? So here,
sometimes like more of this might also
put security at risk of that particular
application or data of the organization
or anything.
Okay,
so the shift basically is you are worried
War.
about the focus on the security,
plus you are also worried about on the
restrictions we might have because of the
security, right?
Yes, yes.
Yeah, so it's like you have the power,
but your hands are tied,
so you're not able to leverage the
complete power as such, right?
Yeah.
So that's one of the shifts the developer
is looking at today. That's true.
Ethical and responsible AI.
There's a wonderful course all of you
have in your...
To I think responsibly, I forgot the name,
but something on those lines.
Very true.
Not only just ethics and responsibilities
as citizens,
the amount of natural resources consumed
by frogs.
If you look at it,
it goes against certain green computing
aspects, et cetera,
because I think there is some.
amount of liters of waters, right?
Many liters of waters spent to maintain
one or two. I think recently, Gemini.
I forgot,
I read somewhere that one prompt in
Gemini uses some millimeters of water.
I think it was around some 20s, I think.
So considering each of us doing so many
prompts per day, it is obviously going to.
..
Um...
do that, right? Impact on recruitment,
okay, that's a very major shift, yes.
And fear of being laid off, but I,
I'm very from the beginning.
Personally, and well, as Kumar,
I interacted with that human first
principle was high, high on us,
so we were sure,
or we are still believing that.
The human effect is required.
We're not still the stage where there is
one person and one person can run a $1
billion company. That's not possible,
at least as of today, right?
So it's always the humans that...
The job is going to transition. Of course,
we have been transitioning. The way I,
so as I said,
I've been taking courses on software
engineering almost 7 to 8 years now.
So many changes have come.
I started with the web Development.
I started with PHP.
I think I remember that first WILP
classes were in PHP some 8, 10 years back.
Then we moved to React, Django.
Then today we are teaching AI Augmented
SDLC. So,
and technologies have also changed.
I will.
I taught in WebEx and then there was one
tool learning part test.
Now we are teaching in TEAMS.
And there are so many changes, right?
So the job is going to change,
but still we will be there.
So impact on recruitment, of course,
new titles will come.
A new job roles will come with the AI
augmentation, etc.
Memory pricing is going crazy, okay,
due to these AI data centers. Yes,
of course, that's true.
Point to 6 millimeters of water per
prompt. OK, so this was the latest, right?
Yeah, I read it somewhere recently,
and they say the Gemini seems to be a
little lesser than the others, right?
I'm not sure, but I recently read it.
Of course, there are many water recycling.
Of course, green,
when you talk about the major players,
they always look at ways in which you can
reduce these aspects, etc. You know,
how do you
Going for...
Saving those resources, uh,
but still that there will be a huge
amount of water.
Usage, except yeah.
So I think I thought I will discuss one
shift,
but we ended up just reading shifts, okay?
So next class we will go into some
examples for each shift, okay?
So I'll start with these five shifts.
Apart from that,
I have noted down a few shifts also, like.
Cost is something which I will have one
more shift discussed apart from the fight
and we'll get into details.
So that is something, Sauram,
that's the question which we have to find
answers for. Can AI jump steps in SDLC?
That's what I asked.
Is SDLC still relevant today?
All of you said yes.
But now that's a different way of asking
the same question.
Can we skip some steps in SDLC because AI
is there?
Maybe they will blur requirements and
design will blur, I think,
because the manager is not going to give
us any PRD document. They might.
But I hope that means some managers also
here.
So they might generate the MVP and give
it to the developer to scale it up to all
users.
So the line will blur.
But AI cannot jump those steps.
Maybe we don't have to micromanage those
steps is what I think.
That's my point of view,
if any of you have others.
answers. Yes,
we'll discuss this in detail.
That's a very interesting take.
Okay, we are already up extra 7-8 minutes.
Have a nice weekend.
We'll meet again in the next session.
Thank you, ma'am.
Yeah.
Thank you, bye.